MY COHOST, EMILY COMPAGNO.
ALSO JOINING US, KAT TIMPF,
DR. JANETTE NESHEIWAT, AND
GUY BENSON.
WE BEGIN WITH ABSURDITY.
THE LEFT'S IMMEDIATE AND FIERCE
DEFENSE OF STACEY ABRAMS, IN
DEFIANCE OF THE SCIENCE, I'LL
HAVE YOU KNOW, AFTER HER
CONTROVERSIAL CLAIMS ABOUT
ULTRASOUND MACHINES WHEN IT
COMES TO DETECTING A FETAL
HEARTBEAT.
>> THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A
IT'S A MANUFACTURED SOUND
DESIGNED TO CONVINCE PEOPLE THAT
MEN HAVE THE RIGHT TO TAKE
CONTROL OF A WOMAN'S BODY.
>> Kayleigh: IN RESPONSE TO
ABRAMS' STUDYING COMMENTS, THE
LEFT REST OF HER DEFENSE, OF
COURSE, BECAUSE I WOULDN'T THEY?
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
FACT-CHECKER TWEETING THIS.
"FOR WHAT IT'S WORK, FETAL
HEARTBEAT IS A MISNOMER.
THE ULTRASOUND PICKS UP
ELECTRICAL ACTIVITY GENERATED BY
AN EMBRYO.
THE SO-CALLED HEARTBEAT SOUND
YOU HEAR IS CREATED BY THE
ULTRASOUND, NOT UNTIL TEN WEEKS
CAN THE OPENING AND CLOSING OF R
MACHINE."
WOULDN'T YOU KNOW, PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, THEY REDEFINED HOW
THEY SEE IT, TOO.
AS RECENTLY AS JULY, HERE'S WHAT
THE ABORTION PROVIDER SAID IN
THEIR WEBSITE ABOUT FETAL
DEVELOPMENT BETWEEN 5-6 WEEKS.
"A VERY BASIC BEATING HEART AND
CIRCULATORY SYSTEM DEVELOPED."
NOW IT READS THIS.
"A PART OF THE EMBRYO STARTS TO
SHOW CARDIAC ACTIVITY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A HEARTBEAT ON IT
ULTRASOUND, BUT IS NOT A FULLY
FORMED HEART.
IT'S THE EARLIEST STAGE OF THE
HEART DEVELOPING."
FOX NEWS HAS REACHED OUT TO
PLANNED PARENTHOOD FOR
CLARIFICATION ON EXACTLY WHEN
THE LANGUAGE WAS CHANGED.
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR A
RESPONSE.
WOULDN'T YOU KNOW?
EMILY, WE LIVE IN VERY SCARY
TIMES, WHERE THERE IS NO TRUTH,
WHERE YOU CAN'T SAY PREGNANT
WOMEN ANYMORE BECAUSE APPARENTLY
THAT IS DISCRIMINATORY.
WHERE YOUR CHILD NO LONGER HAS A
GENDER AS A TODDLER.
A LITTLE GIRL CAN BE A MALE.
WHERE NOW CARDIAC ACTIVITY,
HEARTBEATS, WE ARE CHALLENGING
THAT IN YOUNG BABIES.
IT'S A VERY SCARY TIME WHEN
TRUTH IS OUT THE WINDOW.
THINGS YOU SAID A YEAR AGO ARE
NOW ALL OF THE SUDDEN BIGOTED.
>> Emily: THAT'S RIGHT.
THE ONLY THING MORE FRIGHTENING
TO ME THAN SOMEONE SAYING THIS
ON A NATIONAL PLATFORM IS THE
MEDIA AND THE LIBERAL MACHINE
AMPLIFYING IT.
SOMEHOW CARRYING THAT BALL
FURTHER.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT'S GOING TO
END.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE LAW FOR A
SECOND, ROOTED IN FACT AN ACTUAL
SCIENTIFIC DATA.
THERE IN GEORGIA, WHERE
STACEY ABRAMS PURPORTS TO
REPRESENT THOSE 50 MILLION
PEOPLE, AT ANY STAGE OF THE
GROWTH PROCESS, THE DEATH OF AN
UNBORN CHILD IS REFERRED TO AS
AN UNBORN CHILD, AND PROSECUTED
AS A HOMICIDE.
HOW IS THAT OKAY, THEN, FOR HER
TO SAY THAT AT SIX WEEKS IS NOT
EVEN A HEARTBEAT, WENT FOR THE
PRECEDING SIX WEEKS IT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED THE DEATH OF A HUMAN?
AND LET'S TAKE AMERICA'S
FAVORITE GOVERNOR,
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM, WHO HAS
USED TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO HAVE A
BILLBOARD CAMPAIGN THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY, QUOTING
BIBLE VERSES.
MARK 12:31, TO SAY, "THIS IS WHY
YOU SHOULD GET AN ABORTION.
NEED ONE?
CALIFORNIA IS READY TO HELP," HE
SAYS.
HE'S USED CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO PUT THIS IN
REPUBLICAN GUBERNATORIAL-LED
STATES, AND YET IN HIS STATE, AS
OF SEVEN WEEKS, IT'S A CRIMINAL
CHARGE.
AND THERE IN THE CRIMINAL CODE
IT IS REFERRED TO AS "CHILD
DESTRUCTION AND FETAL HOMICIDE."
APPARENTLY AT SIX WEEKS, IT IS
CELLS.
AT SEVEN WEEKS, IF THE CHILD,
IT'S A HUMAN, IT'S A FETUS, ITS
MURDER.
THERE'S NO SENSE TO ANY OF THIS.
>> Kayleigh: I'D LOVE TO
DISCUSS THE BIBLE WITH
GAVIN NEWSOM.
I COULD GO VARIES FOR VARIOUS
WITH HIM.
IT WOULD BE GREAT.
DR. NESHEIWAT, THE SCIENCE.
WE PUT IT ON THE WALL BECAUSE
THESE ARE ALL RESPECTED
INSTITUTIONS, PRESUMABLY BY THE
LEFT, AS OF YESTERDAY, THEY
WEAR.
THE BABY'S BRAIN, SPINAL CORD,
AND HEARTBEAT BEGIN TO DEVELOP
BY WEEK SIX.
IT IS A HEART THAT CONTINUES TO
GROW.
MARCH OF DIMES, THE BABY'S HEART
AND LUNGS ARE DEVELOPING.
THE BABY'S HEART STARTS TO BEAT
AT FIVE WEEKS.
THE U.K. NATIONAL HEALTH
SERVICE, THE HEART IS FORMING AS
A SIMPLE TUBE-LIKE STRUCTURE IN
THE FIFTH WEEK.
MAYO CLINIC, A BABY'S
CARDIOVASCULAR SYSTEM DEVELOPS
AT FIVE WEEKS IN THE HEART
STARTS TO BEAT SHORTLY
AFTERWARD.
ALL THESE INSTITUTIONS THAT THE
LEFT LOVES, THAT FAUCI I ASSUME
ALLEGEDLY BOWS DOWN TO YOU, WE
NO LONGER TAKE THEM AS
CREDIBLEBECAUSE STACEY ABRAMS, C
DEMOCRAT CANDIDATE, SAID
SOMETHING CRAZY.
>> Dr. Nesheiwat: THAT'S WHAT
WE CALL DISINFORMATION.
I'M A PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR, I'VE
DELIVERED QUITE A FEW BABIES,
AND TAKEN CARE OF LOTS OF
PREGNANT WOMEN.
I EVEN WORKED IN A SPECIFIC OB
E.R., WHERE ALL WE DID WAS USE
FETAL HEART MONITORING AND
ULTRASOUND ALL DAY LONG TO TAKE
CARE OF THESE PREGNANT MOMS,
THESE PREGNANT WOMEN.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT ABOUT FIVE
WEEKS AND FIVE DAYS, YOU CAN
HEAR A FETAL HEART TONE.
I'VE DONE IT MYSELF.
I'VE ACTUALLY DONE THE
ULTRASOUNDS MYSELF.
WHAT IS DISHEARTENING, WHEN WE
HAVE THIS INFORMATION PUT OUT
THAT IS INACCURATE, IT'S
MISLEADING AND IT COULD BE
HARMFUL TO PATIENTS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND,
AND ULTRASOUND IS USED TO DETECT
MOTION.
IT'S NOT USED IT TO DETECT LIFE,
NOT USED TO HERE.
YOU CAN DETECT LIFE WITH IT, IF
YOU SEE MOVEMENT, IF YOU SEE THE
HEART CONTRACTING.
THAT IS INDICATIVE OF LIFE.
BUT YOU DON'T NEED SOUND TO SAY
THERE IS LIFE.
IF YOU SEE THE HEART CONTRACTING
ON THE MONITOR, THAT'S
LIABILITY.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO KEEP IN
MIND MOVING FORWARD.
>> Kayleigh: THAT'S A GREAT
POINT.
GUY, TRIPLING IN ALL OF THIS IS
THE WAY INSTITUTIONS JUST KIND
OF CHANGE THINGS.
APPARENTLY PLANNED PARENTHOOD
CHANGE THEY LINGERED IN AUGUST
AND WE ARE AWAITING AN ACTUAL
DATE ON THAT, BUT TWITTER, IN
THEIR TRENDS SECTION -- THIS IS
YOUR TWEET, I GET TO IT IN, BUT
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE
STACEY ABRAMS SAID THERE'S NO
SUCH THING AS A HEARTBEAT AT SIX
WEEKS.
DOCTORS AGREE ONE DOESN'T EXIST,
AND REPORTS FROM MSNBC AND NPR
CONFIRM.
THAT'S WHY THEY DESCRIBE
SOMETHING IS TRENDING.
IT SEEMS LIKE MORE OF A DEFENSE
THAN AN AGNOSTIC DISCUSSION OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Guy: OF COURSE.
WHEN MY TIMELINE WAS FILLING UP
WITH DOCTORS DISAGREEING ABOUT
THE OFFICIAL WORD FROM
SILICON VALLEY, DOCTORS AGREE,
AND HERE ARE SOME REPORTS THAT
CONFIRM.
I SAW SOME FACT-CHECKERS AND
OTHER PEOPLE SAYING, "LET'S GET
VERY TECHNICAL.
IS IT A HEARTBEAT OR IS IT
CARDIAC ACTIVITY?"
OKAY, INTERESTING DISTINCTION,
PERHAPS, BUT WHAT WOULD YOU DO
IF SOMEONE TOLD YOU THAT YOUR
CARDIAC ACTIVITY WAS ABOUT TO
CEASE IN A FEW MINUTES?
WITH THAT BE ALARMING TO YOU FOR
SOME REASON?
I THINK IT MIGHT.
WE CAN GET INTO THE RHETORIC AND
CERTAIN WORDS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET TO
THE CRUX OF THE ISSUE.
IF THEY SAY IT'S REALLY TEN
WEEKS AND NOT SIX WEEKS, FINE,
LET'S HAVE THAT DEBATE.
IF AT TEN WEEKS YOU HAVE
FINGERPRINTS ON A BABY STARTING
TO FORM, UNIQUE FINGERPRINTS,
AND A DISTINCT INDIVIDUAL
HEARTBEAT, IS THAT HUMAN LIFE?
WORTHY OF PROTECTION ARE NOT?
THAT IS WHAT THIS DEBATE IS
ABOUT, BUT I THINK PEOPLE ARE
ENGAGING IN THIS DEHUMANIZING
LANGUAGE, DEHUMANIZING BECAUSE
THEY ARE AFRAID TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION.
BECAUSE THEIR TALKING POINTS
MIGHT BE INSUFFICIENT, BECAUSE
THEY ARE.
>> Kayleigh: THAT'S A
FANTASTIC POINT.
IF YOUR CARDIAC ACTIVITY WILL
CEASE TO EXIST, I THINK MOST
PEOPLE WOULD BE ALARMED
REGARDING NOMENCLATURE.
KAT, I JUST
WONDER -- STACEY ABRAMS, IS SHE
THE ONE WE NOW LOOK TO FOR
SCIENCE?
THIS IS A PERSON WHO SURROUNDED
HERSELF WITH CHILDREN WEARING
MASKS, AS YOU CAN SEE, WHEN SHE
DIDN'T HAVE ONE ON.
NOW I GUESS -- I KNOW FAUCI IS
RETIRING.
MAYBE IT'S STACEY NEXT?
>> Kat: IF YOU VIEW IT FROM A
POLITICAL PERSPECTIVE, WHY WOULD
SHE CHOOSE TO TALK ABOUT SIX
WEEKS SPECIFICALLY?
YOU THINK ABOUT THE FETAL
HEARTBEAT LAW IN GEORGIA -- NOT
BILL, BUT LAW, IT SAYS PLACES
LIMIT THAT AT SIX WEEKS.
IF SHE WERE ELECTED, SHE WOULD
BE VERY LIMITED IN TERMS OF WHAT
SHE COULD DO REALISTICALLY TO
OVERTURN THAT.
BUT I THINK THAT TALKING ABOUT
IT IN THIS WAY, SHE IS SEEKING
TO CHALLENGE THE LOGIC BEHIND
IT, AND COMMUNICATE TO VOTERS
WHO ARE PRO-CHOICE AND WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS THAT SHE IS
SORT OF THINKING ABOUT IT.
"VOTE FOR ME, MAYBE I CAN DO
SOMETHING."
POLITICALLY, WHEN HE SAID LET'S
TALK ABOUT TEN WEEKS, I THINK
THAT'S WHY SHE TRIED TO SAY
SOMETHING AT SIX WEEKS
SPECIFICALLY, BECAUSE THAT IS
WHAT MATCHES UP WITH THAT LAW IN
GEORGIA.
>> Kayleigh: GUY, YOU HAD A
THREAD ON THIS YESTERDAY.
I ASKED THE TEAM TO PULL PART OF
IT.
HE SAID THIS, "FOR THE SAKE OF
ARGUMENT, LET'S ACCEPT THAT
PARSING BY THE LEFT.
CAN WE AGREE THERE IS A SEPARATE
HUMAN HEARTBEAT AT TEN WEEKS AND
THAT IT'S ETHICAL AND ACCEPTABLE
TO RESTRICT MOST ELECTIVE
ABORTIONS AT THAT POINT?
NO?
HOW ABOUT 20 WEEKS?
STILL NO?"
YOUR POINT BEING, WE WILL TAKE
YOU AT THE HEART BEAT.
AT WHAT POINT DOES THE
RESTRICTION ACCEPTABLE?
>> Guy: RIGHT, AND THE ANSWER,
UNFORTUNATELY, AMONG A LOT OF
PEOPLE NOW -- I THINK THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PRO-CHOICE.
PEOPLE OF GOOD FAITH CAN
DISAGREE.
IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE.
THERE'S ALSO PRO-ABORTION WHERE
IT CROSSES INTO SOMETHING MUCH
MORE GHOULISH AND GHASTLY, AND A
LOT OF ELECTED DEMOCRATS THESE
DAYS ARE UNFORTUNATELY IN THAT
CAMP, INCLUDING STACEY ABRAMS.
WE ARE QUIBBLING ABOUT SIX WEEKS
VERSUS TEN WEEKS, POTENTIALLY.
WHICH HE ACCEPTED A SINGLE
RESTRICTION ON ANY PORTION OF
HER, ALL THE WAY UP THROUGH
BIRTH?
THE ANSWER IS NO.
THAT'S THE POSITION SHE AND
OTHERS SHOULD BE FORCED TO
DEFEND, BECAUSE VERY FEW
AMERICANS AGREE WITH THEM ON
THAT.
>> Kayleigh: 80% WANT
RESTRICTIONS